my wife mrs unlimited said i have to be
a lifestyle brand now
locking up that cash right totally russ
god he's so lame but so good at football
so we're finding spots around gridiron
heights that will
say it with me twelves led ross
we can't have fans yet oh our first
stops in atlanta home to the two-time
super bowl losing falcons i'm here with
lemon peppermint no one calls me that so
what i do is toss the wings to julio for
a bit but then let calvin ridley finish
them off for the cornbread i like to
make things cornier no but i then
turn on the burners and scramble why did
you let him turn on the gas dan
i'm trying my best thanks for letting me
cook it lana there's nothing i like more
than cooking at home
and i'm pretty sure all my guests like
it too you just let him ignore your
recipe yeah we tried not to for years
but uh whatever
all done already but jerry said it takes
time to evaluate if something's good
at the end of the day the real mvp is
someone who enjoys time with their team
but also please please vote for me for
mvp stay tuned for our spin-off
let dalvin cook bro just give me the egg
[Music]
evie wants you to subscribe but
also wants a hug
just because we be team monster
doesn't mean we be monster monster
i must eat to survive